[Music]
[Music]
all right
welcome to all of you for
youtube uh live session on top seven
tips for baby
certification examination
there are some arguments
[Music]
all right
so
all right so
[Music]
security and quality management
now here as part of this
uh
session we will look at
what it takes to become a pap uh
certified professional
now we also look at certain details
about what is that certification is all
about
uh why do anyone would look for having a
baby certification
what it takes what kind of effort
[Music]
and apart from this
which will help you in terms of checking
the specific type of details
which are located in that website
similarly because um
[Music]
so that's how the examination will be so
simple
examination
[Music]
certification is all about
right
so now uh
pmp is a certification offered by a pmi
so the project management issue which
has its
route in
u.s
and globally recognized certification uh
provided by the pmi and then
it has its own recognition and who
should go for team certification
aspiring project managers who have some
amount of experience in uh
uh
we have uh
project managers who are not certified
[Music]
[Music]